foreign
I'm okay I'm okay just to my ankle I
think
they call me koala man I've made up my
life's mission
to clean up our streets
help the innocent
and snuff out evil grass is half a
centimeter too long mate that was a
close one
for I am Kevin yes big Greg you gotta
fix the bloody internet this is the one
where I pull the Peruvian dick fish out
of my cameraman's urethra he's still got
the little bugger that's gone crazy
hasn't he he's perfect go go koala claws
I still need to invent those don't I I
installed cameras in the boys toilets
that's where the deals are taking place
God put cameras in the boys toilet it's
fine no one will ever find them Kevin
old Town's gone psycho evil has been set
loose and I'll take everything from you
koala man
my God bloody hell why do you know you
could dump dead bodies here
this is my town get out of the music
this is the sickest
big day Captain Australia you're just a
wanker
sometimes it feels like I'm the only
thing standing in between this town and
Anarchy
we could go again rougher this time
who's ever heard of going multiple times
we do
hand over your wallet I'm well
trained in the art of grown-up karate
and I even
[Music]